What I already mentioned to you is that this is of course just a worse case view.
So this is what you just calculated here
if we were to consider a billion different possible solutions.
And the numbers would of course get much higher
if we said we are ready to consider 10 billion or 100 billion possible solutions,
but still they would not be in the thousands.
And that's actually the surprising thing
because if we look how well those algorithms perform in practice,
they perform dramatically better.
So for independent set and clique you can usually solve instances far over 1000 vertices,
and for 3 SAT there are even annual competitions
in which participants solve instances with, I would say,
almost in the tens of thousands of variables.
This varies by competition, so there are some competitions
where it's in the hundreds, in the thousands,
but you can solve instances up to 10000.
And the reason for that is that it seems like most of the instances
or inputs to NP complete problems that we encounter in practice
are, in a way, well behaved.
They rarely tend to be worst cases instances
that force our algorithms to run in their maximum time.
And there is also, besides search trees, other very interesting techniques
that you can use to further improve your running time of your algorithms.
I would now like to introduce to you preprocessing
as another technique to deal with NP completeness.